nach meiner rechnung hat die groko noch
genau neun tage nach der hessen wahl ist
garantiert feierabend und mein gott
haben die letzten sonntag in bayern den
arsch voll gekriegt - 21 prozentpunkte
für die großparteien autsch komplett
gelupft alter nach dieser
nach dieser wähler waren ein wahnsinn
ein politisches erdbeben nachdem in
bayern jetzt aber wirklich alles alles
genau so bleibt wie es war ja die
komplette csu spitze macht einfach
weiter als wäre nichts passiert
noch fragen eine frage noch um sie
einmal an rücktritt gedacht hätten wir
das ja auch schon geklärt
drei kreisverbände drei csu
kreisverbände haben schon seehofers
rausschmiss gefordert darunter auch der
mächtige kreis neuendettelsau ja horst
hier findet er habe in der sache alles
richtig gemacht und der satz stimmt ja
wenn man die worte alles und richtig
gemacht durch streicht ich fürchte da
man hat nicht mehr viele freunde in
seiner partei hier ein ehemaliger csu
vorsitzender mit einem wenn man genau
hinhört subtilen ratschlag
ich habe bei 43 prozent selber gesagt
ich trete zurück und machte den weg frei
aber es muss jeder selber entscheiden
quizfrage was sagt dieses grinsen muss
jeder selber entscheiden oder b
horst verpiss dich kleiner tipp ist sb
parteifreund
die steigerung von feind ist
parteifreund ja aber dabei könnte man
auch mal über markus söder reden oder
immer der ist doch schuld dass die csu
massenweise christen stimmen verloren
hat so christen finde es komischerweise
gar nicht gut wenn man das kreuz zu
wahlkampfzwecken missbraucht wer konnte
das an
andererseits kann der markus hat das amt
ja gerade erst übernommen der ist ja der
ist ja quasi noch ein kind ist seit
sechs monaten ministerpräsident hatte
auch nur sechs monate bisher ich bin
jetzt ein halbes jahr im amt habe ich
nur sechs monate gehabt ich habe jetzt
sechs monate zeit dafür
ich bin seit sechs monaten im amt nur
sechs monate sechs monate sechs monaten
sechs monate in sechs monaten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
entweder eltern ich hatte doch nur 600
www bilder weiß nicht mehr wie seine
eigene bevölkerung tickt und jetzt hat
er die quittung in bayern regiert bald
mehr als eine partei können sich das
vorstellen genauso wie im schwange
liegen rest von deutschland wissen sie
eigentlich was das heißt wir müssen uns
muss sagen ihr seid jetzt nur noch ein
ganz normales bundesland wie thüringen
oder bremen
denn wenn die absolute mehrheit einmal
weg ist dann kommen auch bald kaputte
autobahnbrücken dreckige schuhe klos und
wir streichen eure komischen extra
feiertage wie mariä heimsuchung oder
peterchens mondfahrt nix mehr maß bier
ab jetzt gibt es kölsch besser von
ganzen herzen liege bayern kommen eben
deutschlands
[Musik]
ganz ohne punkt
nur noch ein kuscheliges bundesland wie
alle anderen ich würde an dieser stelle
so gern noch was heimisches über den fc
bayern sagen aber das verstößt gegen das
grundgesetz wie wir seit heute wissen
und markus söder markus der erste
koaliert bald mit hubert aiwanger
kennen sie ein oberteil wangerland wird
und spitzenkandidat der freien wähler ja
das wird ein wunderbares paar aktiv die
freien wähler haben 11,6 prozent punkte
geholt mit einer krise idee sie kümmern
sich um die realen probleme der menschen
vor ort da wusste erstmal drauf kommen
als politiker oder der lustige landwirt
aiwanger und der saugeiles supertyp
söder
sie merken ich war ganz kurzem bauer
sucht frau modus haben sich schon zu
einem ersten date getroffen und man
sieht wenn man genau hinguckt direct wer
von den beiden der chef ist für heutige
für jetzt ist es schon mal gewisse
gedanken es okay
danke ihnen donkey kong
großartig so stehen ich war auch dabei
bei der pressekonferenz klare ja schon
froh dass ich kein autogramm geholt hat
vom süden wie niedlich der aiwanger sage
ich ihnen muss höllisch aufpassen dass
er nicht von der csu über den tisch
gezogen wird der soll jetzt mal
ordentlich was fordern ministerien zb
entweder drei sehr große oder fünf
kleine dann wie man natürlich nicht drei
ministerien mit eigenen ministern erhält
man die hälfte der leute zu wenig also
entweder zwei ministerien mehr als 3
also in vier bis fünf ministerien
zwei plus vier bis fünf
so was meinst du wirklich im nasen in
bayern
er wird nämlich hat wirklich verlangt
drei große ministerien oder fünf kleine
oder oder zehn ganz kleine
und bevor die stimmung jetzt so gut wird
meine damen und herren lasst uns mal
über die spd spricht ja halbiert und
einstellig in bayern um die
wahlergebnisse der spd überhaupt noch
erkennen zu können musste die nasa das
hubble teleskop auf bayern richten
letztes doch ich behaupte wenn das in
hessen so ähnlich läuft dann wird es eng
für andrea nahles haben sie die in
letzter zeit mal gesehen
total gestresst und völlig fertig
ehrlich ich weiß nicht wie lange das
noch gut geht jetzt mal ernsthaft ja
sie sagt ihr zuerst in der union ist
schuld an den 9,7 prozent klar 9,7
prozent das kommt zum beispiel davon
wenn man den bürgern als spd vor einem
diesel durchbruch kostenlose hardware
nachrüstung verspricht die dann nicht
kommen von der union erwartet man
verarscht zu werden der spd nimmt man es
übel
in manchen wahlkreisen hanni mit mühe
und not die fünf prozent geschafft in
bayern hier in der berliner
parteizentrale hat die statue von willy
brandt scheel nicht mehr ausgehalten
durchgedreht combo scharf
was ist los mit der spd
der branche wie die brandherde noch
versucht auf dem nach ihm benannten
flughafen einen flieger zu erwischen
aber kommt prinzip hoffnung
prinzip hoffnung nächste woche bringt
thorsten schäfer gümbel die sozen wende
in hessen die original spd plakat hängt
wirklich so in hessen ich schwör's ihnen
zukunft jetzt machen
das ist nicht mal ein deutscher satz
kannst du beliebig umstellen machen
zukunft jetzt oder vielleicht mal quer
gedacht schäfer jetzt gümbel es ist
völlig egal
es ist völlig egal was sollen das ist
bleibt nur eine frage gibt es überhaupt
noch einen funken hoffnung für die spd
wir schalten wir live ins
willy-brandt-haus zu carolin kebekus
carolin krieg deutschlands älteste
partei noch mal irgendwie die kurve
das ist schwer zu sagen oliver
vielleicht geht hier wirklich eine ära
zu ende
die stimmung ist seit dem bayern debakel
jedenfalls verheerend kein mensch weit
und breit zu sehen
sämtliche türen stehen sperrangelweit
auf cosima die natur holt sich das willy
brandt haus zurück die ersten tauben und
obdachlose sammeln leergut es ist
wirklich total traurig angeblich wurde
im zweiten stock sogar schon ein wolf
gesichtet
wer holt sich die schwachen und kranken
genossen also alle
und die spd durchhalteparolen kann doch
keiner mehr ernst nehmen wissen sie was
die lösung sein soll für die alte
arbeiterpartei arbeit die müssen so
sarah bei zurückkehren eine anständige
sacharbeit machen zur sache aber
zurückkommt zur sacharbeit zurückkehren
sarah bei zur sacharbeit sache aber weil
die sacharbeit richtig gute sache aber
angekündigt haben wir das schon öfter
dass witze sacharbeit zurückkehren
aber wir sollten es jetzt einfach mal
machen
und daran wird wohl leider scheitern
sacharbeit wenn ich den scheiß schon
höhere der villa nimmt gute spd politik
in der groko doch gar nicht wahr
so war das in der ersten merkel groko in
der zweiten und überraschung auch in der
dritten
aber sie hatten es nicht deswegen
verleihe ich der spd
das offizielle heute-show prädikat
leider doof beispiel gestern war zum
ersten mal das gute kita gesetz im
bundestag ein spd gesetz hat keine sau
reingeguckt was steht da drin
keine ahnung ich habe ich reingekommen
ist aber bestimmt gut heißt gute kita
gesetz erwecke die müssen raus aus der
gruppe sonst bleiben die teil des elends
hier nahles gibt sich kämpferisch aber
ihr gesicht sagt doch was ganz anderes
wir verschwenden unsere kraft und zeit
jetzt nicht auf interne debatten sollen
wir wollen es wissen in hessen
wir wollen so was von wissen in hessen
die bergmannskapelle probt für die
siegesfeier nach der hessen wahl
man echte das zieht einen alles so
runter und es ist ungerecht ich möchte
mich an dieser stelle mal direkt an die
deutschen wähler wenden
ich verstehe euren groko frust aber
bestraft doch an der ohne nicht immer
nur die spd bestraft doch zur
abwechslung auch mal die die schuld sind
dass überhaupt eine groko haben wessen
schuld ist das denn
was war das keine ahnung bildstörungen
glaube ich glaube ich auch carolin
kebekus bei damen und herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]